jeff is in grand rapids hi jeff welcome
to the ramsey show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up i got a question
yeah a question for you i've been with
the same company for over 30 years
i've invested everything within my own
company i've never ventured out to
you know independent ross and i've got a
daughter that's recently graduated from
college doing exceptionally well
where she's debt-free paid uh the last
two years on her own i helped her out
and she got some scholarships
she's a young 22 year old with a great
job 30 000 in the bank
wow and my question is um
i want to venture out to prepare for the
next stage of my life and get
an elp help or investor pro and i don't
know if we should do this together
i don't know what the best route for us
to go i know that she
i i didn't try to pressure her she's
ready to invest
so she's done everything right and i've
preached into her
which uh i haven't really listened to
you much i've come on to
the last few months from a co-worker so
i'm learning myself
and i just need some guidance as to what
to do what
she should do both of us i don't know if
we should invest i'm
i'm ready to to to hook up with an elp
or a smart
investor pro is this something we should
do together or
i don't know you're independent adults
this is a father a grown lady
and her dad right yes yeah
your retirement plans are not combined
in any way
with the exception when you die you may
leave yours to her but i mean other than
that
no i was just looking for an investment
yeah you can get you can both go the
same guy for investment advice that'd be
fine
so just yeah just click smart buster pro
and you know you can schedule an
appointment and go meet with a guy and
both of you meet with him and then you
can say
you what do you think you're going to
use that guy or you know do we want to
talk to another
one and you could talk that through and
just make sure you get someone with the
heart of a teacher
which you should that's we try not to
have any smart investor pros that don't
have the heart of a teacher
but um yeah it is not necessary that you
both be with the same person it would be
okay if you are but it's not necessary
and you certainly don't have combined
accounts or combined
um anything i mean you could share
information if you want to you could
talk about what we're both doing and how
we're trying to win but
but um yeah let's let's let her
uh she's done a wonderful job of
stepping out on her own and let's let
her do that
and it's a common conversation day that
i've had with parents over the years
where they've just they've been needed
for their coaching and their wisdom and
their guidance and their direction and
suddenly they graduate college and
they're all doing well
and the parent goes what do i contribute
to them now
yeah and that's that shift where just
you're enough
just that relationship yeah the fact
that your dad she's gonna ask you
she trusts you you're a good guy but now
your your value is less about what
you're giving and just the fact that you
are
you're my dad right and that's a hard
transition for parents
it is it is yeah because we've gone from
doing everything for them
yeah and to doing almost nothing yeah
well
and i think we were probably doing less
than we thought but we sure gave that
advice and we sure said hey
don't forget to and then you look up and
you're like i don't know i kept the
grand babies the other day they do a lot
[Laughter]
you're doing a lot for them i'm just
saying there's a lot there's a lot of
maintenance involved in them critters
oh yes there is